eigentlich wollte sie gar nicht mehr
schwanger werden sie hat nämlich schon
zwei kinder mehr sollten es nicht werden
eine vietnamesin ließ sich daraufhin
eine spirale einsetzen doch sie wurde
trotzdem schwanger und bei der geburt
des kleinen jungens entstanden dann
fotos die um die welt gehen das baby kam
mit der spirale seiner mutter in der
hand zur welt total süß aber auch
ziemlich entlarvend für die spirale als
verhütungsmethode wie sicher ist sie
denn tatsächlich als verhütungsmethode
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit isabelle
moretti sie ist gesundheitsberaterin
frau morelli ja wie sicher ist so eine
spirale ist so was ihnen schon mal
untergekommen solch ein foto also es
ging so ein foto tatsächlich vor ein
paar jahren schon mal um die welt aus
einem anderen land in deutschland ist
sowas soweit ich das weiß noch nicht
passiert bisher allerdings muss man
sagen spielen sind im normalfall standen
sehr sicher sie gehören tatsächlich mit
abstand zu den sichersten
verhütungsmethoden allerdings gibt es
eben keine 100 prozent sichere verhütung
außer enthaltsamkeit
und das ist genau meine frage gewesen
welche ist denn die beste und die
sicherste verhütungsmethode klar
enthaltsamkeit sagen würde ich sagen
fast 100 prozent aus bei maria da hat es
nicht funktioniert mit der
enthaltsamkeit aber sonst für uns
normalsterbliche welche
verhütungsmethode sollte man denn wählen
das kommt natürlich erstmal auf den typ
an
man guckt sich in dem fall immer zwei
sicherheits angaben an einmal unsicher
ist die methode potenziell wenn man
tatsächlich alles richtig gemacht
das ist der methoden index der war jetzt
bei der spirale beispielsweise bei 0,6
das heißt 0,6 von 100 frauen werden
trotz gerade schwanger also sehr selten
dann gibt es noch den anwender index
also wie sicher ist dass im realen leben
und da sind über die spirale bei 1,0
also eine von 100 frauen selbst trotzdem
schwanger damit ist die spirale
tatsächlich noch mit dass sich aus der
verhütungsmittel denkt bei der film
beispielsweise liegen dir aufgrund der
vielen den zielanwendungen bei einer
anwender sicherheit von zwischen 6 und 9
was bedeutet zwischen 6 und 9 frauen von
100 werden trotz pille schwanger
das heißt wir sind bei der kupferspirale
schon sehr sehr weit vorne was sie sich
da sind wir jetzt beim thema sicherheit
jetzt ist aber auch verhütung sagen wir
mal immer einem trend unterlegen klar
die pille war ganz lange im trend dann
irgendwie nicht mehr es ging hin zu
beispielsweise apps mit dem zählen der
tage mit der temperatur also sagen wir
mal natürliche verhütungsmittel was ist
denn im moment im trend bei den jungen
mädchen also tatsächlich sieht man das
alles was mit waffen zu tun hat immer
unsympathischer wird offensichtlicher
und der trend dazu geht definitiv hormon
frei zu verbinden jetzt ist natürlich
die koffer varianten wie die spirale
auch eine hormon vermietung der trend
geht aber tatsächlich richtung komplett
natürlich bedeutet man besucht sollte
tage mit ess ich bin sehr vorsichtig was
apps betrifft weil ich finde man muss
die methode vorher kennen bevor man mit
einer eps erlitten
und die methode bedeutet als frau man
muss sowohl seine körperzeichnungen zum
beispiel lichtsteiner der muttermund
beobachten können und richtig auswerten
können und seine temperatur beobachtung
dass in kombination mit meiner
gesundheit thermale methode die von der
sicherheit her eigentlich direkt nach
der kupferspirale kommt nämlich 18
frauen von 100 werden trotz dieser
methode ungewollt schwanger alle andern
nicht
ist also eine sehr sichere sache wenn
man weiß wie man es macht also auf jeden
fall sich mit der thematik beschäftigen
dann gibt es auch kein böses erwachen
ganz herzlichen dank für ihre tipps zu
diesem thema ganz herzlichen dank
isabelle moret